ladies and gentlemen 1983 Academy Award
nominee for Best Supporting Actress Amy
Irving or add the Kennedy Award
recipient Richard Dreyfuss
evening in the grand tradition of
American screenwriting I would like to
offer an actor's rewrite and I would
like to say I love you and good night to
my son Benjamin and my daughter Emily
well then I get to say good night to max
good night max in the category of
original screenplay the nominees are for
big
Gary Ross and an Spielberg who
demonstrated that boys will be boys even
if they're 35 years old for Bull Durham
Ron Shelton who wrote about baseball and
other games grown up to play or a Fish
Called Wanda John Cleese Charles
Crichton turned a good number of things
upside down including John Cleese
for Rain Man
Ronald bass and very Morrow for their
chronicle of newfound brotherly love
or running on empty
Naomi phoner who wrote moving notes from
the new underground and the Oscar goes
to
Ronald bass and Barry Mara Lorraine
Thank You Academy members and thank you
United Artists and the goober Peters
company in particular I'd like to thank
Tony Thermopolis and Roger Birnbaum and
Stan Brooks and to Dustin and Tom and
Barry and Mark my heartfelt gratitude
for for making the movie and for
breathing life into these characters and
into this script and the Gary Lauder
Mark tingloff and Mike Adler and to Bev
and clay and Zoey my love for your
forbearance and to Kim and finally to
marna for her courage I thank you so
very much
I'm just going to say goodnight to
Jennifer and Sasha and leave it it
ladies and gentlemen with mr. Dennis
cream and the camera
performance in Dangerous Liaisons his
Michelle Pfeiffer
and carried his stuff because we went to
different high schools together I
thought that worked great I got from
ultra math but be not Rain Man was an
original screenplay written directly for
the screen rewritten directly for the
screen and probably re rewritten for the
screen the following five wonderful
screenplay started life as something
else a book of letters in one case a
serial written at the turn of the
century for a newspaper you might say
that they were all pre rewritten for
best screenplay vessel material from
another medium the nominees are Frank
Galati and Lawrence Kasdan for their
screenplay of the accidental tourist
based on the Anne Tyler novel
Christopher Hampton who adapted his own
play Layla's andante ruse into Dangerous
Liaisons
Anna Hamilton Phelan screenplay and a
Hamilton Phelan and tab Murphy story
whose screenplay gorillas in the mist
was adapted from the story of Dian
Fossey Christine Ed's art who took
Charles Dickens storytelling tapestry
and spread it across the film canvas in
her screenplay Little Dorrit jean-claude
carrière and Philip Kaufman who based
there screenplay for The Unbearable
Lightness of being on the novel by Milan
Kundera
Christopher
well this is great but anyone would fly
across the Atlantic to get a kiss from
Michelle Pfeiffer I want to thank Norma
Hammond and Hank moon gene and my fellow
producers for showing a beginner the
ropes
I want to thank normal for putting me in
touch with Bernie Brillstein Peter
Chernin and Eileen Maisel without whose
courage I think the film wouldn't exist
and faith in it and finally I want to
thank to care recipients of this should
little a clue who's having about as good
a year's as possible to have if you're a
dead writer and and of course Stephen
Frears who created the atmosphere for
everyone to be able to do that their
best work so Thank You Steven Thank You
Michelle John and Glenn Thank You France
Thank You America thank you